Halloween's coming up right and you're
tired of having the jack-o'-lanterns out
and the I don't know to skeleton the
glow-in-the-dark thing you know that guy
so clearly what you need in your house
or out front of your house is a giant
origami zombie with his intestines
spilling out of his body so we're gonna
learn how to do just that today this guy
right here from the book I'm gonna guess
it's called a zombie got me but I don't
think I'm allowed to look down because
I'm on camera yes
zombie gommi he has a name in the book
and that name is Seymour guts do you get
it do you get it good okay now what
you're gonna need for this two pieces of
paper one for the top of his body one
for the bottom of the body I'm not gonna
tell you which part of the body the
intestines come from that'll just be a
surprise one thing you should know
though is there's gonna be scissors
involved in a fair bit of cutting so if
you are an origami purist please don't
be upset it's just the nature of the
beast
not this beast just proverbial beast so
first piece of paper I have taken the
liberty of doing a little bit of
precreasing to make this early part a
little bit easier so basically what
you're gonna do is you're gonna take
your piece of paper do I sound like the
mini micro Machines man I kind of feel
like I'm right now you're gonna go
diagonal one way white side out diagonal
the other way white side out then you
were going to turn them over and do the
long rectangle colored side out long
rectangle color side out and then you're
gonna take the top you see that magical
that is called the preliminary fold in
origami but then there's more to it than
that see if you're gonna fold in fold in
take the top fold it down and then based
on that you will be able to take this
and open it up and then you're gonna do
the same on the other side and now what
you have if you fold up the long tips
and you keep the diamond side down is
you have this what you're gonna do then
gets a little bit tricky here you are
essentially going to sink in the bottom
of the diamond so that that comes inside
the body of the piece and you are left
as you can see the bottom of the diamond
is now inside and nested in there all
proper like so now you basically have
this this and you've got a
back here okay now we're gonna slow
things down a bit first thing we do is
here come the scissors sorry about this
Japanese originators of the ancient
glorious art of origami but when you
make novelty zombies with their
intestine spilling out this is just
something you need to do so you are
going to cut on both sides of the model
just this top layer you're gonna cut
down along that crease so there's gonna
be four of those cuts total hate using
scissors on origami don't erase the
whole process but when you have to
simulate curling intestines there can be
no substitute alright so now that you
have these what you're going to do is
bring these down in the front only then
you are going to bring it back around
like so tuck it inside the model the
toughest part if you don't do a lot of
origami or if you've never done origami
before if you think the origami is the
name of a professional wrestler or
something like that is the folds that go
out to the corners that extend to the
corners are where it's gonna get screwy
and that's really where the exactitude
comes into place you really want to be a
perfectionist about this especially at
the beginning of a model because as the
layers start to pile up and you're
making strange crimps later in the model
it's just gonna get to be a blunt
squashy mess
that sounds really unpleasant but it is
it's gonna be a bone squashing mess so
you have you have tucked in your flaps
on both sides and you are now going to
bring this up look at what you got here
you got a big square with your with your
four flaps now you are going to do
what's called a mountain fold on both
the top and the bottom of this and
mountain just means when you're looking
at it you are forming a peak it is
essentially a convex fold rather than a
concave fold which in origami parlance
is known as a valley fold so I assume
I'm never going to be able to run for
public office after delving so deep to
the origami
but that's cool okay so now you have
you've made your mountain folds both on
the top and bottom and now it's gonna
get a little more little tiny bit more
complicated you're gonna do what's
called a pleat fold and that is
essentially I'm gonna hold it up like an
elementary school teacher so you can see
for the whole class and what we are
essentially going to do is accordion it
so you are imagine you're making like a
little zig zag on this side like that
and a little zig zag like that let me
fold it a little more neatly so you can
see what I'm actually talking about now
as you can see I made a little bit of
zig zag there and it pleats in hence the
term pleat fold magical how they come up
with these names it's really who knows
how they did it they must have some sort
of Advisory Board now we are going to do
a strange little thing called a reverse
fold
so essentially imagine making this fold
right here but instead of just making a
fold you're gonna make that fold and
then use it to make what's called a
reverse fold so you are going to tuck
that inside along the fold line that you
just made and it ends up being kind of
hidden away you do in making these want
to ideally make them as symmetrical as
possible because the more regular it
looks the more regular your zombie with
his intestine spilling out will be
though I guess a zombie with his
intestine spilling out isn't really
gonna look all that regular maybe his
irregularity is his regularity okay so
you have your reverse folds made and now
you are going to take these and you are
going to valley-fold them the top edge
of the page of the shape down to the
midpoint and because of the reverse fold
that you've made is going to kind of
have a natural limit to it so you Valley
fold the top and the bottom and here is
where the rubber meets the road if your
reverse fold was not ideal it's going to
be tough to get up to the exact
act spine of that shape but you will do
the best you can because you are a
trooper and I believe in you and if you
do not heed the limits of the paper
you're gonna hear a tiny tearing noise
and you will look down and you will say
my god he has led me astray I led myself
astray so I have no one to blame but
myself but as you will hopefully see a
tiny little tear such as this one is not
gonna stop us from origami glory so you
have major Valley folds now it's time to
cut some more
so let's wield these instruments of the
devil in origami terms and we are going
to on each of these points we are going
to cut across here and we are going to
cut along that midline down to where the
pages meet so first you cut across and
second thoroughly cut there and you
repeat that on both sides these are
going to become these splayed undead
fingers of the zombie which
coincidentally was a name of a hardcore
band that I played in in high school so
let's get rid of these no one needs
these recycle though save the planet so
you've got this going and now you are
going to fold the top of this little
rectangle box down to the bottom and you
are going to extend that out so now we
have this now it is time for some more
reverse folds which are going to follow
from the top corner of each of these
extensions down to about midpoint so
first you're going to make this on the
front Oh behave please so there's one as
you can see the first of four and it's
gonna end up looking like this if you
really want to see what's going on
inside its kind of a plea tear averse
folded mess you're gonna do that now on
the other side both in the front and the
back I don't think I've heard myself
talking this much without interruption
in a very long time this is what PBS
hosts have to deal with all the time
isn't it
crippling terror of hearing their own
voice in in going out into a void
does this look futile on camera does it
look like I'm struggling here it's not
that I am it's just that I've never
thought about what folding origami must
actually look like all right so you have
your four little protrusions here that
you have so masterfully reverse folded
and then thanks to all this work we are
going to take our scissors and we are
going to snip them off and we are going
to clean up our workspace because I
never do it and it feels fancy to do it
oh no it's time to cut more and what is
what is the real world equivalent of the
origami war crime that is all this
cutting be sure you cut in the right
direction also for the scissors because
if you don't it's just gonna end up
looking like a doctor Nick Rivera did
your surgery everybody but we are gonna
splay out the layers of that based on
the cuts that we have made I'm gonna
cover up the disgustingness of that one
botched deal we are gonna take those
flaps and we're going to refold them
along the same lines but just in the
opposite direction so they essentially
are tucked back behind themselves turn
those Valley folds into mountain folds
how green is your Valley I don't know
why I just said that then we're gonna
take the bottom and bring it up to the
top and guess what we're gonna do now we
are going to cut because the person who
made this book do Wayne I went to
actually did go to high school with a
guy named do Wayne we are going to cut
both in from the sides though not all
the way to the midpoint we're gonna cut
down along the midpoint not quite
halfway so first we're gonna go down a
little bit here along that midpoint and
we are going to cut in here you are
going to make a valley fold here and you
were gonna make a valley fold here and
imagine it as being displayed
shirt-collar of a zombie because that is
exactly what it's going to be I don't
know why so many things on the zombie
are splayed but I guess that's what
happens when you die and are reanimated
and then we take the top triangle the
top layer of this and we full
down so that the tip of it extends just
a little bit beyond the bottom of what
is essentially the model right now and
then after that we're gonna do two
little folds up two little Valley folds
okay now it is time for a little
pleating we all have to pleat we showed
you how to pleat so let's pleat so we
pleat by doing this we fold down - it is
almost flush with the lower layer on
that but we don't we leave a little bit
of wiggle room we do a one of these
pleats here that we have that and then
we are going to valley-fold at the
bottom of this up and we are going to
tuck it under the top so we have what is
essentially a couple of triangles all
talk to me leave behind themselves and
now we're gonna fold this whole thing in
half so as you can see you have the arms
of the zombie and you have the head of
the zombie kind of coming into view a
little bit you can kind of see what is
the brow and what is gonna be the nose
and what is gonna be the kind of law I
don't know MA
zombies don't exactly have the best
dental care so let's just call them all
you are then gonna take the head I just
grab a little guy by the chin I'm gonna
tilt him up a little bit squash it down
I want to keep his facial features
altogether you don't want his nose to
jump off his face but you do want to get
a little bit of clearance between his
chin and his body so then what you have
back here are these odd little corners
and you want to try to reverse fold
those and that's an odd it's gonna look
a little strange it's a it's a little
bit of a clumsy fold but essentially all
you're doing is squaring off the corner
of his skull now you are going to fold
up where his brow meets his nose just
gonna fold that up a little bit turn
that into it I guess I and I brow
quizzical zombie eyebrow works for me
and now we're gonna turn our attention
to the fingers which are fingers because
of all that horrible cutting that we did
earlier so what we are going to do is on
each of these we are going to for
it down like this we're going to fold it
down like why isn't this green that
should be green
I'm gonna go off-book for a second
because I may have screwed it up and and
we're going to take each of these double
thickness fingers we're just gonna give
it a little snip oh well I almost said
to snip a root God that would have been
a nightmare
I guess admitting that I almost said it
is worse though because I managed to say
it and display some crippling self-doubt
so that's always good okay so you've got
your fingers I guess more or less this
is a little Tuffy part so just you know
try to make sure there are a few of them
try to make sure they're displayed as
though to grab you and eat your brains
make some folds along the arm so that
when the model is finished as you can
see coming around now it's got a little
bit of depth we're gonna put him aside
right now this ugly mug and we are going
to move on to the bottom half now I used
blue granted it is not a salvaged denim
blue but whatever pants you think a
zombie is gonna wear just go with that
and we're going to go with a very
similar beginning white side out
diagonal fold I know I'm concentrating
both because I can feel my tongue kind
of poke out of the corner of my mouth
and because I'm actually able to
accomplish things most of my life does
not go that way
so I guess the lesson here is you focus
a little bit and anything's possible so
then you've got your you've got your
diagonals and you were gonna turn it
over and you were gonna make your
rectangular folds with the colored side
out in my case that is blue in your case
it could be a glorious patterned washi
paper whatever you're using some
high-end origami finery that I can
either pronounced or afford so then
you've got those and you're gonna do
your little top edge pinch every time I
do this and I've done this I don't know
how many times in my life it never
ceases to amaze me I love that do you a
little like water balloon thing
that is known as the preliminary fold
and then you're gonna do that extra
little thing where you you you get
the end of it not that is all collected
at the end but there's all the loose
stuff at the end and you will make your
little symmetrical folds into the middle
follow that up the imprecision would
which I am doing this is staggering and
disappointing but I hope you will
forgive me so then you fold down the top
of the base and that gives you the
creases along which you can bend this up
once again okay and then you do the same
thing on the other side make sure
everything is nice and pointy and sharp
down there probably the only time in
your life you will ever say that
sentence hopefully do we have standards
and practices here is that gonna get
bleeped or is it the internet where
anything goes
there's still the Wild West like privacy
scholars used to say this on your other
side and you are gonna flatten it all
out so precisely and neatly that you
will get a gold star next to your name
to shame knowing that all these things
I'm saying what I like to call patter
she's gonna fall by the wayside cutting
room floor maybe when the criterion
collection Edition comes out we'll have
it as a featurette okay so you have
that's really it all step one believe it
or not that that's what a base fold is
all about so there's more cutting you're
gonna cut the top layer here and in the
back just on one side though so you're
gonna cut one side and then on the back
side
we're going to unfold this the top part
not the bottom part you're gonna unfold
this and you are going to kind of refold
along those lines but in the opposite
direction again so you're gonna turn
that Valley fold into a mountain fold
take a little care that it doesn't have
a bunch of edges bumping up against each
other back in the interior of that fold
I'm gonna do it on the other side as
well
you need to open up the model just a
little bit to make this easier totally
fine there are no rules here
it's like Lollapalooza I don't know what
that means
okay so you've got your edges tucked
behind themselves into the thing and
then you are going to you're basically
gonna take this layer and fold it over
that and then turn it around and take
this layer and fold it over that so you
have in the front the two white flaps
and in the back it is all just solid
color now what you are going to do is
take the right side of your model here
and you're gonna kind of pull it to the
side and then kind of pleat it back in
there so if you kind of just grab the
point and swing it out a little bit and
then flatten it out you can say look mom
or dad or my two dads depending on if
you are a sitcom fan look what I have
done then you're gonna take your sides
and you are going to valley fold it so
here you're gonna pull you're gonna fold
this point to basically to the center
line just about you don't have to and
you're gonna want to make sure that that
is a straight kind of up and down a
vertical nice little thing over here and
then over here you are going to fold
similarly not as far in but what's also
going to happen is it's gonna it's going
to kind of pull this and there's gonna
get a little a little aesthetically
maybe less pleasing it's all part of the
process there's no such thing as
ugliness so this is also going to be
basically
straight up and down edge here and now
you're going to Valley fold this top of
the model down almost all the way to the
center model here as far as this stupid
fold will let you from these two points
you're gonna valley fold this in but
because of the top you're gonna have to
squash this part down does that make any
sense I knew you'd get it I have so much
faith in you and now it's intestine time
people grab your scissors and you are
going to basically cut long skinny
strips along the length of this white
piece of paper so have some have some
fun go little nuts
if you want to color this in make it
more intestine colored if you want to be
using paper that is like sickly flesh
colored maybe in in the back in the
reverse instead of white that's a one
way to do it also depend if you're going
for verisimilitude or just kind of a
conceptual flick at the idea of
intestines spilling out of a zombies
body I know there are Lehrer lists among
you so I'm gonna leave that up to you
you're gonna fold down see now when I
did that little fold into the middle
what I neglected to say was we should
probably fold both layers into the
middle like that so you can do that now
we haven't screwed anything up I mean I
have that you haven't you're still
glorious snowflake okay
and at this point you were going to take
the top and you are going to fold it
down so that it covers it runs into the
top of your intestines and then you are
going to tuck it back inside the
intestines as one does now it is time
for personal expression time you're
gonna take all your little intestinal
strips and you are going to twist them
and curl them as you see fit to best
evoke human offal
the awfulness of human offal and you are
making the unseen scene and Foucault and
Derrida would have things to say about
this I'm just saying all this stuff but
you are let me take a second and put
this down and make all my intestines as
twisty and curly and disgusting as I
possibly can and feel free to get
involved you've got kids and you want to
paint this stuff and you want to make it
as gooey and disgusting as possible
that's great this is actually a pretty
fun kind of geek dad geek mom thing to
do if your kids are old enough to not be
terrified by the concept of zombies now
you got a big mess of intestines and
then you're gonna take your feet and you
are going to make a little reverse fold
here so he has a little something to
stand on and then you're gonna take his
other foot and you were gonna do an
outside reverse fold which feels less
natural to paper but you're gonna do it
anyway to give him something to stand on
and then you can kind of adjust him as
you see fit and you're gonna put the top
on the bottom and you put them on you
okay I understand now why he is named
that way and maybe you can lean him
against something because he doesn't
really want to stand that well how does
he look kind of gross obviously I'm not
doing the best job with the intestines
but that's where you know that's where
the arts and crafts on urine comes into
play so here we have seen more guts put
them in your house get ready for
Halloween and the book is zombie Ngami
by du
Wain in your book stores now